Congratulations.
You've finished the final project,
and reached the end of this course.
You've created a data-driven
web application, and
have a beautiful restaurant
menu app to show for it.
However, we've only scratched
the surface of web development, so
keep going from here.
If you're interested in learning
more about the Flask framework,
the Flask documentation is
a great place to start.
Add more features to the restaurant
menu application, or create a new
application of your own, using some of
the more advanced features of Flask.
I will also provide some links
in the instruction notes,
on deploying a Flask application,
to be shared with the outside world.
If you're interested in
adding more HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript features to your website,
take some time to check out some of
Udacity's awesome frontend classes.
Wherever you decide to go next from
here, I strongly encourage you to
immerse yourself in the web
development community.
Read blogs, experiment, and share your
work with other web developers and
enthusiasts like yourself.
[SOUND].
Well, sounds like it's dinner time for
me over here.
Thanks for
helping me show what's on the menu.